bonjour merci d'être avec nous en direct
sur arte france alors un recours devant
le conseil d'état parce que vous estimez
que le gouvernement ait finalement est
en train d'entraver le droit de
manifester c'est bien ça oui absolument
ce droit de manifester est entravée par
le décret du 31 mai dernier qui interdit
les rassemblements de plus de 10
personnes dans l'espace public s'est
justifiée par l'urgence sanitaire mais
cette urgence sanitaire ne doit pas
confisquer la démocratie et ce d'autant
moins que des choix de société très
importants doivent être faits
actuellement après cette période de
confinement alors juste un mot par
rapport aux reportages
malheureusement ce n'est pas à partir du
10 juillet que nous pourrons de nouveau
nous rassembler
mais peut-être le 10 novembre puisque
vous le savez un projet de loi est va
être débattu pour maintenir cette année
cette interdiction de manifester
justement pour les considérations
sanitaires qui sont en réalité un
prétexte pour interdire ou en tout cas
est tout fait les mobilisations et
mouvement social alors on sert le
gouvernement on vous l'avait dit
annonçant en tout cas des raisons
sanitaires celle qu'on nous rappelle
depuis le début un distanciation social
mesures de sécurité est-ce que c'est pas
logique que les manifestations soient
interdites
finalement non c'est pas logique parce
qu'on peut tout à fait se rassembler à
plus de 10 personnes tout en respectant
les gestes barrière surtout quand on est
dans dans l'espace public c'est à l'air
c'est à dire à l'air libre et que chacun
porte un masque et que chacun respecte
une distance de sécurité et cette
interdiction elle est contre productif
parce que en interdisant tout
rassemblement
il n'est pas possible d'organiser avec
les autorités d une organisation qui
pourrait justement respecter ces gestes
barrières et imposer le port du masque
lors de ces manifestations
donc c'est tout à fait contre-productif
et vous le voyez bien cette mesure à
être complètement illégitime et en tout
cas elle n'est absolument pas respectée
puisque dès la fin du confinement
plusieurs rassemblements et plusieurs
manifestations ont eu lieu en nombre que
ce soit pour honorer la mémoire de
georges floyd et se manifester contre le
racisme et les violences policières que
ce soit en faveur des travailleurs sans
papiers
donc ces manifestations mais cette
interdiction était légitime et ses
manifestations et ces rassemblements ont
lieu malgré tout et ce qui est
extrêmement problématique c'est que
monsieur castaner a déclaré à propos du
rassemblement de mardi dernier en
soutien en mémoire de georges fleuve qu'
il n'y aurait pas de sanction et que
cette grande mobilisation était toléré
ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire qu'en
réalité c'est le fait du prince
c'est le règne de l'arbitraire parce que
malgré cette interdiction absolue et
générale
un ministre de l'intérieur considère que
certaines manifestations seront tolérés
et d'autres pas donc c'est à la
discrétion du gouvernement et ce n'est
pas comme ça que nous considérons que le
droit doit s'appliquer la règle de droit
elle doit être appliquée à tout le monde
dans les mêmes conditions et ce ne doit
pas être le raid de lundi de
l'arbitraire et j'étais j'ajoute
n'allait y aller allez-y j'ajoute que
c'est incompréhensible
c'est incompréhensible cette
interdiction générale et absolue sans
contrôle du juge a priori parce que des
mesures beaucoup moins restrictive était
en place au moment du pic de l'équipe de
l'épidémie entre le 15 mars et le 15
avril d'air
et l'interdiction de se rassembler porté
sur des rassemblements de plus de 100
personnes en plein pic de l'épidémie à
un moment où on est en phase 2 de
déconfinement où on peut aller dans les
centres commerciaux où on peut aller à
la messe où on peut aller dans certains
parcs d'attraction il est absolument
inconcevable et incompréhensible qu'on
ne puisse pas manifester se rassemblent
et exprimer des opinions politiques ou
syndicales dans l'espace public
m et seillière est merci d'avoir été
avec nous en direct sur rt france
rappelle que vous êtes avocate au
barreau de bordeaux et président du
syndicat des avocats de france partie